hello my name is Tamra chambers and this
is Tamra just saw today I saw Blade
Runner 2049 which is of course the
sequel I say of course it is is it a
sequel it's not a reboot I think it's a
sequel to the 1986 1982 masterpiece by
Ridley Scott Moira that's actually a
movie that I had seen before in my
lifetime Blade Runner I saw it in
college so when I was dating it's like
you've never seen this let's see it so I
saw it and I honestly was listen guys I
haven't seen anything at the time I
hadn't seen Jurassic Park or any of the
Chamber's never seen movies so I don't
think as a 18 year old 17 whenever I saw
that I was quite ready for Blade Runner
as a film I have seen it three times
since then I have grown to definitely
appreciate it ends and I'd really enjoy
it but yeah I saw two to impress some
some dude didn't love it the first time
it's actually in a video that I recently
made on my personal channel III I was
extremely excited to see this there's
been a lot of trailers that I've seen
and so tight for this this new 2049 film
but really without giving a whole bunch
away it looks like it was in the same
vein as the original and and I was like
I have high expectations for it so today
I woke up I went to a 3d IMAX viewing of
Blade Runner 2014 just like so you'd be
very like the absolute best screening
that I could see of it and
oh my god you guys it's it's stunning
it's so beautiful and so well-crafted
and just it blew me away I don't I talk
about this a lot I don't like long
movies and this is two hours and 44
minutes and every frame every shot
everything was so beautiful and well
deserved and just needed to be there and
and they didn't feel like it was two
hours and 44 minutes to me though I do
think that some people might find it
boring it is a slower paced film it
takes a second to settle into itself and
and you know you don't see Harrison Ford
so like two-thirds of the way in which i
think is awesome because this feels a
its own thing it kind of feels like it
doesn't need to have all of the things
from the first movie because it's its
own thing
I'm gonna try to do this with no
spoilers soon so I was talking in
circles around myself the story is about
Ryan Gosling's character of Kay who is
the Blade Runner in this film who is
working with the NYPD know the LAPD
that's at the city and trying to solve a
mystery where he needs the help of
Harrison Ford's character which is Rick
deck heart and it's just a lot of
government genius and a lot of memories
and a lot of just heart man it's so good
I definitely cried at the end the
credits started to roll and I was like
wiping tears away it was all of us
oh good
I think Ryan Gosling plays the lead
character he's this very subtle actor
he's got some lines thing that could be
funny but he's just so dry and like just
so very like kind of deadpan that's it's
all just very like I can't really tell
it's incredibly perfect for this
character that he's playing kay there's
so much silence and there's so much
sattell acting like I've said a million
times good job camera well done but
there's so much of that throughout the
film that it could easily have been
really cold but there's still so much
just like feeling and depth find
everything Harrison Ford was so good you
guys so good in a way that I feel like I
haven't seen in a while from there's a
board like he wasn't that like scraggly
like whoa you know the one also the
actress I could look up her name she was
in San Bernadino Sam said no San
Junipero good board good guy
Mackenzie Davis I recognized her from
that black me RepA sewed because I also
just bought this I'm gonna show you all
cuz I think it's absolutely beautiful
and I may or may not have been tipsy one
night and like impulsive poops
it's so beautiful yes in utero black
mirror heaven is a place on earth isn't
that gorgeous
but anyways she this character was in
the film and was was lovely ooh
Jared Leto was also just very good like
light - Jared look he was as perfect as
a very creepy villain I guess the whole
movie was slightly horrifying it had a
very big sense of just like horror and
I'm scary like creepy vibes that just
like God I'm your skin the whole time
not not any like
jumped scares or any kind of thing if
you're not a fan of horror films you're
still going to enjoy this I imagine but
it it was a really beautiful sense of
uneasiness God so study the movie is
incredible like shops would go by and I
would like whisper under my breath just
whispering to myself the theatre was a
very packed but I I saw it at 11:15 a.m.
on a Friday so it made me so much so
badly let me start that sentence over it
made me want to see the first one again
so so badly and and some really nice
subtle callbacks but nothing that was
just like remember this remember the
first one bra you know it was like well
done it was so moving you guys oh god oh
girl yes there's such a weird thing when
you're dealing with the what are they
called
replicants such a weird thing when it's
like this might not be received well but
like it like it like an active sex doll
kind of thing like there's a lot of
advertising in the city of Los Angeles
this dystopian Los Angeles of these like
sex dolls that who are like they live
there replicants so that's always a
weird thing to me um just because you
know what's happening with those the
money it's it's kind of like rape be a
bit so that's weird and odd and not my
favorite thing in the world I can't
think of anything that put me off that
like that I didn't like in the film one
of the most beautiful films I've ever
seen in my entire life
it's so stunning and so well darn it to
the point where wounded watching it it's
kind of like how is this real how is
this how is this real how is this
in a world where the emoji movie exists
it's just so masterful it's a goddamn
masterpiece
if this doesn't win so many others I
just don't I won't understand it's so
good oh I so suggest seeing this I can't
even give it a grade like it's just so
good if Cody were here I think he'd give
it
he really likes fast and furious so I
think a hundred fast and furious is out
of a hundred Tokyo trips I Kobe is out
of town in Texas today so last time
alone I can't suggest it highly enough
like just go see it it's so beautiful
it's really beautiful and well done it's
also something I feel like you don't
have to see the first because it is such
its own thing I know a lot of people who
haven't seen the original don't worry
about it go like read a summary real
quick on Wikipedia and like go see this
film it's beautiful know that you're in
for a long haul it's 2 hours and 45
minutes but again it's just so gorgeous
it's so beautiful damn damn damn I
really wanted to see Flatliners but I've
been hearing really bad things that's
unfortunate but I really do want to
still see it I might just see it post
something about my personal channel me I
am planning on seeing that thank you so
much for watching I'll see you all very
soon
[Music]